and you guys know they go and welcome to
ask IJ i'm justine and this is the
question/answer show where I'm you guys
know I never really give you full
answers okay where's my questions why
are they not here why are they not here
oh why is this such a process okay
finally oh my gosh they're smashing of
some Jason who's asking me who my
favorite youtuber is you could not say
to someone who is your favorite youtuber
there's so many of us there's so many
people have so many friends that I
cannot be one I can't I can't even do it
Steven Stefan wants to know who what is
my overall favorite app from the App
Store it's like asking people who is my
favorite youtuber it's just that one oh
my god nobody answered a question yet
look at that
it's your they do I like better one
direction or Oz oh definitely awesome
there's just no comparison because let
me tell you what I will never ever
forget that he sang me a happy birthday
at playlist live I think it's gonna be
two years ago
I love seeing youtubers do amazing
things so congratulations Austin I hope
to see you um whenever I see you again I
can eat one food that I loved and never
get fat or ill would you I definitely
would and that food would be there's
this local candy store called Sara's
candies back where I lived in Pittsburgh
they have this Easter Egg it's a
chocolate covered do peanut butter
inside and it is the most delicious
thing and last time that I had one my
mother said it to me for Easter I ate it
all I was so sick but it was so worth it
Miriam I mean I'm a Miriam Miriam dermo
a great name what's your favorite
childhood memory and why see here's the
problem
my memory is absolutely terrible I've
been working on my draw my life which is
actually another question over here
somewhere I said but do I draw my life
yes I moved all my life but I'm having
so much trouble remembering there's a
lot of little stories that I know that
if this happened and I don't remember
them to tell you guys if I could be a
lead actress in a movie which movie
would it be and why well
I'd like to be the lead actress in a
future movie that hasn't been made yet
so no but it would be so cool another
question that I didn't really answer I
can answer this one Lulu is asking you
what I'd rather have a dozen roses or a
dozen doughnuts huh dozen doughnuts
PEGI dragons Peter Julian like
Assassin's Creed or black ops 2 more
like I'm single come on do you even know
do you even know me do you even lift bro
if the only thing you could eat was put
not next question no idea what happened
to will face Wednesday well today is
Wednesday or it might not be Wednesday
depending about what I post this video
but if you guys some little well faces
it's basically when you take an
extremely unflattering photo of yourself
you just gotta go like this it looks a
little something like that and then you
post it and hashtag it well face there
you have it you love it they forgot
about it goes back to a memory thing no
this one who Twitter if Apple actually
make cars but they have window oh oh
see what you did there and I've actually
never heard that joke before I don't
know how but I you're pretty slick Paul
wants to know when does the agency drop
my life we already answer that mm-hmm
Arielle wants to know have I never got
plastic surgery or thought of getting
plastic surgery um I have not got any
plastic surgery and I've never really
thought of getting plastic surgery but
somebody was threatening my life and
said listen you have to choose now you
have to go get processer I would
probably get my nose undaunted when I
was little I fell and I hit a step and
it's kind of you guys make fun of me a
lot so but nothing that I really care
enough to get fixed because let me tell
you what when you get a nose job I've
watched some crazy things and I've heard
horror stories I mean people like the
doctors go in and they break your nose
to restructure it Matt thought to me I
don't like pain that looks like all the
questions that I have for you guys today
thank you so much for watching don't
forget to Like and don't forget to
subscribe so you'll know when I post a
new video
be sure to leave me some comments below
as questions for the next episode and
people are having a party outside and it
sounds
fun they probably think I'm crazy
because they can totally hear me if I
can hear them then you can hear me
yelling like a crazy person here
Photoshop I'm really gonna go now I love
you guys
I'll see you soon